[Music]
it's like a blast from a not so distant
past
1500 people packed together in an indoor
arena in leipzig for a concert of german
singer-songwriter tim bensko
the fans here are volunteers part of
restart 19
a study to see if and how big events can
be held safely in the era
of covet 19.
concert going is my hobby i go to 20 30
concerts a year
and now that it's not possible because
of corona i want to support this study
to help find out how we can still hold
concerts
safety measures including a negative
corona test and a thermoscan
were needed to get inside
[Applause]
everyone taking part in this experiment
even the press
have been given these medical grade face
masks
and been ordered to keep them on at all
times
we've also been given bottles of
disinfectant
which we use to clean our hands as often
as possible
contact tracers worn around the neck
track the distance between concert goers
to identify where in the area fans group
too closely together
it doesn't sound very rock and roll but
the one pop star present was satisfied
with the results
this summer we had to endure drive-in
concerts so for us
this feels like the first step towards
normality
restart 19 is not a perfect experiment
wearing masks at a concert and keeping
social distance
are not real world conditions
[Applause]
or you can say we have data that doesn't
quite correspond to everyday life
but get you half the way there and going
halfway
is better than not going forward at all
singer tim bensko and the scientists
carrying out this experiment
don't think it's the answer to all our
corona problems
but the results of this study expected
in about six to eight weeks
could make it possible to hold concerts
live sports and other big public events
again
and to do so safely
and scott roxborough was there in
leipzig he joins me now hi there scott
i imagine it was probably really nice to
see some live music again after a little
while
so many months but you know we saw
people in masks they were having to sit
down
did this feel like a real concert yeah
i think the first thing i noticed was um
instead of smelling pot when i walked
into the
arena i smelled disinfectant uh that's a
big jump from how we used to experience
pop concerts um yeah i mean it's very
different obviously and it does have a
sort of a bit more
sterile environment um but i have to say
um i'm not a huge fan of tim bensco but
he did put on a show and when the lights
go down
and people start dancing and clapping
around you you do have to feel like oh
this is almost like how it used to be
but still not quite
uh not quite normal and we have to keep
in mind this was a scientific experiment
who who
paid for it oh well um it's uh yeah a
very big scientific experiment actually
cost a million euros to put this on for
the day
um and the cost is split between the two
governments of saxony where leipzig is
located and
saxony anhat it's neighboring estate in
in eastern germany
um and uh basically uh they're putting
up all this money because
they want to find for have some sort of
database that they can use
to basically help out the events
industries in their states to help
all these thousands of people who are
out of work who can't go
back to work will be setting up concerts
like this and they want to give them
some sort of
scientific basis to say we can develop a
plan that will allow you to be safe but
allow you to put on these type of events
again and as you say these industries
have taken just a massive
hit in this pandemic when uh what are
they trying to get from
the data and when can we expect to see
uh any results
um well fairly soon for such a large
experiment i mean they said they're
crunching stuff like four tetrabytes of
data which i don't even know how big
that number is it's huge
um but they expect in four to six weeks
they'll have the first uh um data uh
uh they'll now analyze the data such way
that then they can uh
say something about what the study uh
that took place uh
uh on saturday um and um basically
what they want to do is they want to
identify where the risks are because at
the moment people don't really know they
don't know
um what hot spots what are the hot spots
what's the dangerous areas
in an event like like a big concert or a
big sporting event um
and so with this they're basically
creating um with the data they've
gathered people with all their tracers
they're going to create mathematical
models
that they are going to use to show to
say okay if you take this type of
approach if you have say two entrances
and everyone crams in
where are the danger zones how dangerous
is it if you have eight entrances and
you do
maybe a different model modeling or have
different types of
hygienic controls how safe is that and
with these models they hope to be able
to go to the politicians and say
look we can do it this way and this is
safe enough and then maybe we can have
these type of events again
super interesting scott roxborough from
dw culture thank you